communiqué tombé à midi aujourd'hui
communiqué de jean paul delevoye
l'ex commissaire aux retraites sans
doute ne pouvaient-ils plus tenir
après les révélations successives sur
ces omissions dans ses déclarations à la
haute autorité pour la transparence de
la vie publique
il avait oublié de dire qu'il avait des
mandats souvent bénévoles dans un
certain nombre d'institutions
il avait aussi minoré un peu
fâcheusement les rémunérations qu'il
avait perçu pour certains de certaines
de ses responsabilités
il l'a dit mon erreur est d'une légèreté
coupable je la paye c'est la dure loi de
la responsabilité
hervé nathan c'était c'était plus
tenable il fallait qu'il parte jamais
fêté plusieurs puisque faut quand même
rappeler que jean paul delevoye a fait
quelque chose de contraire à la
constitution c'est la prostitution la
loi fondamentale du pays précise bien
qu'être ministre est une fonction unique
exclusive donc on peut absolument pas
avoir d'autres occupations
d'une part et d'autre part jean paul
delevoye qui est un ministre est donc en
charge quand même de faire appliquer la
loi a montré le mépris qu'ils pouvaient
montrer sur les textes de la république
qui disent que quand on devient ministre
eh bien on fait une des cassures
exhaustive des ses seins de saignant
potentiel d'intérêts sur les 5 l'année
précédente
quand on est ministre on est quand même
là pour faire respecter la loi les lois
et on doit la respecter lui-même donc
oui c'était plus de là puisque de toute
façon parquet national financière allait
bientôt avoir dossiers transmis et
qu'elle allait forcément être obligé de
provoquer une information judiciaire est
peut-être éventuellement on allait vers
une vers une mise en examen à terme
c'est sa mère certain temps mais fabre
hall donc le poids le le ministre en
charge de la réforme des retraites en
pleine grève pas général puisqu'on en
est pas là mais en plein conflit se
retrouver fragilisé où il fallait qu'il
démissionne et à mon avis il ya nice ou
d'histoire pas tout à fait terminée par
l'homme
pas totalement soulagé parce que farid
il explique comment en fonctionnement
interne personnes a prévenu jean paul
delevoye qui faisait quelque chose de
contraire à la constitution c'est un
petit peu compliqué mais normalement de
premier ministre il a sous ses ordres un
grand un haut fonctionnaire qui
s'appelle le secrétaire général du
gouvernement dit sgg qui est
spécialement chargé d'informer les
ministres nommément disant vous devez
faire ça vous devez tous déclaré vous
devez vous devez le rompre leurs liens
d'intérêts vous devez démissionner de
tous les possesseurs alors soit le sgg
l'a pas fait et à mon avis ça ça
m'étonnerait pas ce que c'est des gens
qui sont plutôt carré soit il ya autre
chose il va bien falloir un moment donné
que le problème que premier ministre
s'explique sur comme ok c'est pourquoi
il ya un tel bazar dans son gouvernement
voilà c'est pas tout à fait finie traoré
plus entre guillemets couvrir jean paul
delevoye en dix ans a tellement besoin
il n'a pas arrêté de lui trouver des
excuses croissant et quoi il a coup il a
cru à sa sincérité jusqu'à midi jusqu'à
ce que vous dites qu'au moment où il a
fallu qu'ils démissionnent les ministres
bredouillait monsieur le drian a
bredouillé quelque chose d'assez bizarre
c'est oui il croit la sincérité et puis
d'ailleurs si le premier ministre crois
moi aussi je le crois donc voila c'était
à peu près le se livraient alors qu'on
essaie quand même espèce de théâtre dont
vous tout le monde savait que c'était
intenable
parce que depuis la sphère cahuzac ce
genre de choses sont évidemment très
bien vu moi je pense personnellement que
jean paul ii loi fait partie c'est le
politicien ancien s'est pas vu mon âge
quand même chez c'est pas une cc c'est
pas péjoratif qui avait beaucoup
beaucoup de 2
kiki qui supportait pas la législation
post cahuzac voilà qui pensaient que ce
qui existe et ça ne les concernait pas
ils étaient habitués accumulé beaucoup
ayant la preuve avec monsieur delevoye
surtout quand on a un qui est quand même
un ancien dans la fonction donc accumulé
beaucoup et voilà ça faisait partie de
la vie politique et donc il y avait
beaucoup de mal avec c'est la question
qu'on se pose à cette heure c'est de
savoir si cette démission menace ou non
la réforme des retraites
alors d'abord parce que jean paul
delevoye et était le spécialiste de ce
sujet ça fait des mois qu'ils
travaillent dessus alors ça on peut
imaginer que d'autres responsables
gouvernementaux actuels ou futurs
seraient susceptibles de se saisir du
dossier et de le maîtriser assez vite
mais il ya aussi le fait que jean paul
delevoye était très apprécié de ses
interlocuteurs syndicaux y compris
d'ailleurs ceux qui n'étaient pas
d'accord avec la mise en point
la mise en place par don d'une retraite
par points écoutez par exemple y verriez
c'est le scrutin général de force
ouvrière
il vient d'apprendre la démission de
jean paul delevoye donc c'était en fin
de matinée et il continue de le ménager
le haut commissaire jean paul delevoye
s'était mis au service de ce projet je
suis en profond désaccord avec lui là
dessus maintenant c'est quelqu'un qui
était un homme de dialogue qui est un
homme de dialogue il a été médiateur
reconnu de la république il a présidé le
conseil économique social et
environnemental et il portait sans aucun
doute avec beaucoup de conviction ce
projet c'est quand même un peu étonnant
j'ai des fans trop bossé toute cette
avalanche de compliments pour quelqu'un
avec lequel force ouvrière comme la cgt
était en désaccord frontal
maintenant qu'il est parti de toute
façon jean paul delevoye n'était plus en
première ligne depuis qu'il avait dit
publiquement qu'une clause du close du
grand père
appliquée à tous sous signerait l'échec
de la réforme voire après il s'était
fait recadré en conseil débit je crois
par emmanuel macron c'est c'est edouard
philippe qui avait pris la main mais
sans vouloir quand même là la mort du
pécheur
je trouve que la façon dont il s'y est
pris et pas très élégante même dans la
déclaration à laquelle vous faites
allusion à un moment il parle d'
instrumentalisation de ses erreurs c'est
pas de simplement des erreurs qu'il a
commises mais comme hervé l'a rappelé
c'est une violation de la constitution
tout simplement
après il explique que c'est sa femme qui
s'occupait de l'administratif
on a connu plus élégant et enfin pour
couronner le tout jean paul delevoye
faisait partie de ces
piliers la majorité qui donnerait des
leçons de morale à tout va rsa on va y
revenir après justement sur ce côté
absences d'exemplarité
mais est-ce que ça va être difficile
georges kuzmanovic de trouver de
nouveaux interlocuteurs pour les
syndicats aussi apprécié qu apparemment
l'était de le voir ce qui était dit sur
sûr de le voir peut-être faudra-t-il
ajouter une chose c'est qu'il est
entouré de quand même de toute une série
de ministres et d'autres membres de la
république en marche qui sont
déliquescence avec la justice ces
personnes démissionne de rien et houston
délicatesse pardon de négoce
c'est le gouvernement qui est un délit
questions sur le parc français acquis au
mais je pense à tous ceux qui ont des
intérêts croisés comme monsieur colère
madame busin bon les choses allaient
notre ancien président son nom m'échappe
de l'assemblée nationale non non
l'actuel pardon en série une façade
d'origine et à monsieur keller
gouvernement monsieur ferrand et à la
sphère benalla qui traînent le meilleur
tout à fait étrange sans qu'on comprenne
ce qui se passe puis 6,8 fin beaucoup il
ya le direct il ya le directeur de
cabinet de monsieur ferrand j'ai pas la
liste mais finaliste effet plusieurs
pages sans que personne ne démissionnent
sans que personne soit enjoint à
démissionner même carrément défendue par
le président à appliquer comme ça a été
le cas avec monsieur benalla donc des
fois on peut dire que ma foi par rapport
aux autres j'ai pas tellement tricher
bon ca de 7 devrait passer comme les
autres je sais pas peut-être qu'il s'est
dit ça en étant une ancienne folie d'un
ancien monde on regarde ces questions là
maintenant est-ce que ça va est ce qu'il
ya des interlocuteurs mais oui vous
l'avez dit c'est monsieur le premier
ministre qui est interrupteur
interlocuteur maintenant sur cette
question et qui a repris la main qui
justement s'est fait recadrer
ils ne manqueront pas d'interlocuteur je
le vois à mener les consultations sont
visiblement trop écouter ceux avec qui
il a parlé pendant 18 mois il est 10
heures hier et les frustrations sans
écouter entendre voilà chers internautes
qui nous suivez vous considérez
majoritairement que non la démission de
jean paul delevoye ne menace pas la
réforme des retraites ou peut-être 61% à
vous prononcer en ce sens citoyen p r
nous dit avec un peu d'ironie sans doute
que avec autant de mandats et de
fonctions il était n est pas étonnant qu
il est bâclé ce fameux rapport sur la
réforme des retraites
et puis dominique plutôt inquiet tout
refaire maintenant c'est impensable pour
ce quinquennat c'est cuit c'est lui qui
portait la réforme ils étaient censés
maîtriser le sujet depuis deux ans
maintenant après en avoir discuté avec
les partenaires sociaux
rachel e business vous pensez que on va
trouver facilement d'autres
interlocuteurs
c'est vrai qu'il ya le premier ministre
mais lui il est sur une ligne assez
raide c'est lui par exemple
edouard philippe qui porte le
le projet de vouloir installer un âge
pivot c'est ce que je pense une erreur
stratégique il est pas là pour ça de
toute façon il a d'autres fonctions à
remplir qui ne sont pas celles là j'ai
du mal à croire en plus que les
partenaires sociaux puissent trouver un
écho auprès de lui un la question je
pense qu'un passage de témoin est
toujours possible mais quelle est la
marge de manoeuvre des deux côtés en
fait c'est qu'elle était la marge de
manoeuvre de delevoye là dessus parce
que on sait qu'il est pas complètement
autonome indépendant et un gouvernement
derrière lui et puis de l'autre côté du
côté des syndicalistes
quand on entend par exemple soit vous
retirer l'ensemble du projet soit on
continue on peut s'interroger sur la
marge de négociation qui existe et je
pense pas que le principal le principal
frein à cette réforme
quoi qu'on en pense soit aujourd'hui le
départ de le voit c'est bien plus
profond que ça et il apparaît comme une
espèce un petit peu de cerise sur le
gâteau sur ce voile à ce seul hic colère
qu'on voit s'exprimer depuis le 5
décembre pour défendre un petit peu jean
paul delevoye
il ya quoi et je vous emmerde d'abord je
pense le départ évidemment ne remet pas
en cause la possibilité ou pas de faire
la réforme qu'il s'agit s'il s'agit de
répondre à ces questions la réponse est
non en revanche il ya au moins un
personnage pour lequel c'est un peu
embêtant c'est le premier ministre parce
que ça veut dire que comme il peut pas
compter quand même sur madame busin qui
normalement est la ministre des affaires
sociales puisque c'est le cqp qui a déjà
beaucoup de mal à se dépêtrer de
l'hôpital puisque la haine elle est
menacée par la démission de 650 chef de
service dont sept dans les hôpitaux
tellement ça se passe mal on la voit mal
s'occuper de la retraite sur lequel
d'ailleurs elle n'a pas montré une
technicité formidable or c'est quand
même un dossier qui à la fois
techniquement très compliquée qui
concerne quand même 40 millions de
personnes une de rien puisque c'est
pratiquement toute la france au travail
qui est dans le futur sera à la retraite
donc c'est quand même 40 millions de
personnes et est donc il n'y a plus et
quand on regarde bien aucun des
ministres par exemple même genre en
france
jarre darmanin qui est l'autre ministre
de tutelle de la sécurité sociale comme
il des comptes publics
il sait pas où il a une peut-être une
maîtrise du dossier du côté financier
mais pas du côté des relations sociales
c'est tout ça qui avait fait qu'il y
avait jean paul delevoye donc ça veut
dire que maintenant le premier ministre
il est tout seul en première league
c'est lui qui va devoir assumer c'est
compliqué oui oui enfin il avait quand
même quelques alors juste pour l'aspect
vraiment politiciens ce genre de jean
paul delevoye il avait quelques
avantages par exemple il connaît très
très bien le groupe
lrm ça compte c'est lui qui la
constituent et quasiment celui qui a
fait les listes électorales pour les
législatives
quasiment c'est lui qui a appris à
obtenu à l'émulation de chacun des
députés ou à peu près qui siègent à
l'assemblée quand on doit faire passer
une réforme aussi importante que celle
là il ya des longs des morts devant le
demande parlement ben il faut quelqu'un
qui tiennent le choc et de soins du
l'agent peu de loi il était il est pas
si facile que ça remplace et moi je vois
pas dans le spectre politique de
personnalités qui en plus
ali al contacts avec les partenaires
sociaux est la république en marche
c'est la dernière chose qu'ils savent
faire de toute façon ils ont décidé
depuis depuis le début a par jean paul
deloy grosso modo tous les députés tous
les ministres affichent le plus profond
mépris pour les partenaires sociaux en
considérant que tout ça c'est vieux
monde donc ça a été compliqué pardon il
ya éventuellement film grandjean mais
d'autres mais dont on se demande où
séoul et conseils ont mené ce puisque
c'est un ancien proche de la cfdt et
dont on voit que cissé ses conseils
qu'on monte en termes de résultats par
exemple de rapports entre l'exécutif et
la cfdt est un échec total pour le
moment donc voilà c'est pas si simple
voilà donc c'est pas c'est un caillou
dans la chaussure des premiers ministres
ont à dire et alors il y a effectivement
dans cette démission toutes les
questions qu'on peut se poser sur la
gestion du dossier des retraites
et puis il ya aussi peut-être tout le
problème de l' exemplarité ou non qu'on
les responsables du gouvernement c'est
un sujet qui était assez familier de
jean paul delevoye puisque en 2010 il
était alors médiateur de la république
il expliquait savamment combien quand on
avait des responsabilités on devait se
montrer exemplaire je propose de
réécouter cette séquence désormais culte
aujourd'hui nous devons très clairement
affiché tous ceux qui de près ou loin
celles et ceux qui pré sident des
décisions de caractère public
elles sont les conflits d'intérêts qui
éventuellement on pourra leur reprocher
mon angoisse c'est de voir aujourd'hui
la remise en cause de la confiance dans
la décision publique
parce qu'il ya un manque d'éthique un
non respect hrithik b c'est vrai
aujourd'hui sur l'ensemble d'un certain
nombre de comportements qui se doivent
d'être exemplaires
l'exemplarité est aujourd'hui un élément
de construction de la confiance la
transparence est aujourd'hui aussi
quelque chose de tout à fait déterminant
et en écho à ces images vous cite cette
réaction de nicole qui nous dit quand on
travaille pour un gouvernement qui parle
sans arrêt de transparence et de
moralisation
on doit être irréprochable et puis bon
sens paysan c'est le pseudonyme
j'imagine et nous dit les politiques
n'ont pas encore compris la défiance de
la population
c'est vrai georges kuzmanovic que cette
affaire delevoye ça va encore renforcer
cette défiance peut-être sur le thème
faites ce que je dis mais ne faites pas
ce que je fais il demande des efforts
aux français mais eux mêmes sont en
exonère un peu facilement rue très
sûrement
heureusement qu'il a démissionné
d'ailleurs si tout n'est ce qui était
resté ça aurait été catastrophique ça
aurait été bien pire que que s'il avait
démissionné donc le coup et pour les
retraites pour la forme de retraite sera
moins grave
maintenant avec la démission de delevoye
mais oui on a quand même une série
d'hommes politiques qui se font prendre
la main dans le pot de confiture et qui
s'en sortent avec de légères réprimandé
puis continuant carrière politique assez
facilement ajouter à toute une série de
parti politique je pense spécifiquement
parti socialiste qui a trahi tout son
électorat de base
on ne ne faisant pas ce qu'il avait
promis quand
quand il portait un leur programme oui
on a une défiance vis-à-vis de la classe
pour une classe politique qui est
tendanciellement quand même perçu en
particulier ceux qui sont proches du
pouvoir comme ne disant pas la vérité
étant sûrement pas transparente ça a
toujours été comme ça juste trop bien ce
que vous pensez que ce soupçon peu pesé
particulièrement sur sur le régime en
place ou sur la majorité en place depuis
2010 est l'inconvénient le handicap du
régime en place c'est qu'il s'est voulue
meilleur que tout le monde plus
transparent que tout le monde
à tel point on se rappelle que la
première loi votée sous l'ère emmanuel
macron c'était celle pour la
transparence de la vie politique portée
enfin conçu en tout cas par françois
bayrou qui a été obligé de démissionner
puisqu'il était pris dans la peine dans
la sphère des emplois fictifs du modem
ça commence pas bien qu'elle commençait
pas bien donc c'est peut-être la raison
pour laquelle l'opinion est
particulièrement sévère avec ce que vous
appeliez ces donneurs de leçons là c'est
que ils ont été particulièrement donneur
de leçons mais l'époque a changé aussi
je crois que la sphère cahuzac marquant
même un tournant de ce point de vue là
parce que c'est lui c'était le donneur
de leçons en chef et il avait fait de la
lutte contre la fraude fiscale son
principal cheval de bataille
mais ça c'était insupportable c'est ce
commentaire de double b est intéressant
je ne comprends pas pourquoi le
président au premier ministre de lévis
repart alors j'imagine qu'il s'agit de
tact uriel il s'agit des ministres qui
peuvent être concernés par une affaire
publique plutôt que d'attendre leur
démission
c'est mieux qu'en milieu des missions de
lui même on a l'impression que c'est
plus c'est plus authentique dans la
démarche
en tout cas ça te paraît plus sincères
disons là on a attendu une semaine les
jours était long et encore on parle de
la partie immergée de l'iceberg à toutes
les affaires soit qu'on ne connaît pas
soit qu'ils n'ont pas pris encore de
proportions trop importantes
et puis ensuite à chaque
chaque élection on va manifester une
espèce de surprise à l'égard de
l'absentéisme ne comprenant pas pourquoi
les gens ne vont pas voter etc
c'est c'est extrêmement triste parce que
vous l'avez dit c'est un lien qui rompu
à la fin de tous ces politiques on se
dit que le spectacle lors d'échéances
est plus beau que celui de leur réussite
et c'est un petit peu ce qui caractérise
aujourd'hui ce gouvernement est le lien
qu'il a avec avec les électeurs quand tu
voudras être vertueux pour cela en
prenant que je me trompe tout quand même
rappeler qu'il a quand même déclaré que
la gagner 3 ou 4 millions qui ont
disparu qu'il a dépensée en bon vin est
en bonne vie est en réparation de croix
de salle de bain au touquet bonfils qui
soit poursuites judiciaires en armes et
bien sûr pendant l'essai après que j'ai
là qu'il a fuie et puis de revenus et
que son patrimoine était pas et en
dessous de celui de monsieur poutou qui
est ouvrier chez ford qui est bon c'est
un petit peu ridicule ce n'est donc pas
sorti la déclaration monsieur plutôt
être trente mille et macro et 1,0 après
adressé à rothschild comme comme comme
ça c'est un peu étrange et et puis ces
deux ventes d'alstom vient électrique ou
à la fin on se retrouve avec son
assistant et baylet qui se retrouvent
patron va tout ça tout ça est
extrêmement louche est pour lui sans
aller plus loin sur ce dossier parce que
c'est pas le sujet mais il y en a
énormément de ce genre de dossier dans
ce gouvernement et le citoyen qui n'est
pas nécessairement moyens écoute entend
tout ça et elle se dit que il ya quelque
chose de pourri au danemark les yeux
laisse la parole à nos internautes pour
conclure romain magicien qui nous dit
faute avouée est à moitié pardonnée pour
l'interrogation
je ne sais pas si ça évitera le naufrage
de la réforme et le marquis regrette
cette affaire de le voir car celui ci
passait bien avec les partenaires
sociaux
on continue à parler de la crise en
cours si vous le voulez bien mais pour
se demander si le gouvernement pourrait
faire preuve de davantage de fermeté il
a demandé à plusieurs reprises qu'il y
ait une sorte de trêve de noël
mais c'est difficile à obtenir y at il
des marges de manoeuvre y at il des
moyens de pression du gouvernement